foreign
Kansas City Missouri wood is up Charlie
hey John how's it going partying man
what are you up to
oh just working very cool dude what's up
um so it's kind of a complicated
question but also not you know doesn't
seem like a huge deal but it's really
been bothering me okay bring it on
so
uh recently I I just got engaged to my
fiance and uh her parents have
generously gifted us
um 10 acres to build a house on is it is
that 10 acres connected to a family
place
so yeah there's 30 I mean it's 40 total
but no one lives here so
um but it's theirs
yes
um so you know they just used it
recreationally over the past you know
whenever they bought it 20 years ago
um and you know didn't do much upkeep
just harder to farm the fields and then
you know Road four-wheelers or dirt
bikes or whatever
um so over the past year and a half two
years
spend a lot of time and money
um thank you talk directly into your
phone Charlie
um there you go is this better much
better yeah
yeah okay so over the past you know year
and a half two years we've spent a lot
of time and money fixing it up you know
putting in a road building
you know basically the utilities for it
so that it's usable are you already
living together
uh yes okay I was wondering why you were
fixing up your girlfriend's parents
place but okay all right yeah it's I
mean we've been dating for a very long
time so okay all right um and we should
have engaged probably before we did but
that's besides the point
um took me a while to get around to it
um
so the problem comes with my fiance's
dad and it's not that big of a problem
and he's a wonderful guy to be around
except for when it comes to working out
at this you know this place we're
building a house
um
I I have very high standards
um you know with my stuff I like to keep
it nice and and keep it looking good and
it seems like every time he comes out
here to help
uh you know things get ruined you know
roads get trashed you know
stuff gets mowed that shouldn't be mowed
um you know that type of stuff and I you
know it makes me angry so you know kind
of like you say in your your podcast
when you get angry walk away and I try
and do that you know so that way
I don't
you know I don't know the right word for
it but it
how much of the frustration here of your
anger is
because you're not clear
do you have a vision for this place and
then he comes to help so I when I moved
to my new place out here I I live on
some Acres out here I mowed my neighbors
I I live next to an elderly neighbor I
mowed their field for them it took me
four hours I was trying to be a good
neighbor show this new person how great
and I mowed their hay field down
like yeah I I totally screwed up dude
my wife came home and she's like she
grew up out on acreage too and she's
like what have you done and I was like
I'm a great neighbor and she was like no
no you're not but I didn't know I didn't
know so is there a Clarity issue or is
he just like a good loving
disaster
and that's part of it whenever we bring
something up you know he apologizes and
says he won't do it again and then the
next time he's out here something
happens so at what point do you quit
inviting him out
but the thing is you know it's his place
as well that's the problem but he's
doing it all out of the goodness of his
heart
you know
um so it's it's I I don't know
here's the magic line you got to choose
guilt over resentment
because you're going to get dangerously
close to getting sick of the side of
this guy
well I that's the thing I mean he's
wonderful to be around elsewhere I love
seeing him but then when he comes out
here it's like oh no yes and so
choosing guilt over resentment meaning
I'm gonna have to choose the guilt I'm
gonna feel by telling him hey I want to
be like I want to learn how to do all
this stuff and so I'm asking you to not
help with this property anymore
with the fencing we want to build with
the House Clearing with the field
clearing whatever's going on I want to
do this work myself
or I want to go through the bid process
and I'm so grateful for your heart but I
want to do this and you're going to feel
really guilty and he might feel hurt
and he might even say I just gave you 10
acres you can't tell me what's it and
then the other option you have is I'm
not going to take 10 acres adjacent to
Family Farms because they're always
going to think it's kind of ours
yeah or I'm gonna buy the whole thing
I'll buy the whole P I'll buy all 40
acres from you and it's just mine
yeah well that's what I mean we kind of
talked about
um but I mean that's the thing he they
say you know we can do with it exactly
how we want you know we've maintained
all of it we mow all of it we you know
do all the stuff for all of it and then
y'all have any kids
no not yet when you when y'all have kids
you'll realize oh that's not what they
that's not what they mean
yeah like yeah of course you can do
whatever you want to with it except not
really because it's kind of still mine
because I gave it to you
so what is your what does your fiance
think about this
she thinks you're being ridiculous
no she agrees um why won't she tell her
dad hey dad would you stop doing this
well if there's communication problems
there correct so um uh here's what's
about to happen if it hasn't already
you're going to start getting your
frustration at him is going to start
bleeding off on her
yeah that is not the case I mean I it's
not there but I'm telling you it's
coming
I'm telling you it's coming
um
so
how do I
I mean it's not necessarily my place to
you know tell him what to do so like how
how do we go about this I mean it's your
place to say hey please stop coming on
my property
uh I mean it is your place
unless he gave it to her and it's not
technically yours yet
um
well and and she agrees that we don't we
want him to come out and have fun you
know ride dirt bikes whatever just
please stop working you know stop have
you ever sat down with a with a with a
I I don't know like a piece of graph
paper or a map and said here's our Dream
for this
and here's what we want to do and here's
what we're not going to do anymore you
ever done that
um what do you mean meaning have you
ever sat down with him and said hey
these 10 acres here's what our plan is
we're going to put a pond over here
we're gonna have grazing over here we
want to raise chickens over here and so
we're not going to mow this area at all
anymore
um this area over here I want to hire a
company to come in and do some
professional Pond work
um I know you can probably do that I
could probably do that but I want to
hire this out and I want to learn how
the GC process works how the general
contracting process works and what it's
like to do I want to learn all this
stuff it's going to cost money it's
gonna take time but I want to learn how
to do it over here I'm building a
chicken coop if you could help me with
that that would be amazing right and so
what you're doing is clear as kind
you're being very direct on and then if
he goes and mows a field down that
you've sat down and said hey we're
preserving this then you can say hey man
we talked about this then it's a
violation right now it's just a guy
trying to help and it's like hey I got
it dude he doesn't know what I got it
means and he sees that you're busy and
he he wants to be a good father-in-law
you see what I'm saying it just kind of
gets messy because there's no clarity
yeah
so sit down and tell them how we
actually feel
um well and I think I think it's before
how you actually feel I think it's
here's what our Our intention is with
this 10 acres here's our plan and here's
how I want to see this thing play out
here's how me and my my fiance soon to
be wife plan on doing this stuff and
then it's just it's just very clear for
him you don't have to sit him down and
be like and I'm really pissed off that
you did it like this and like this it's
less about that and more about here's
our intentions for this if he violates
those basically you're doing is you're
giving it boundaries if you violate
those boundaries now we got another
conversation to have
see but that's kind of I mean we've
already
every time something happens we ask him
to not do that then you know something
else happens so I mean so is he doing
the same thing over and over
uh I mean not really
um
it's but it's just give me an example of
something he's just blown
uh we planted a bunch of trees and you
know they got Bush hogged down but
they're not like they're five foot trees
you know how can you you miss those or
you know uh We've installed a you know
or a quarter mile road
um and then he goes and drives a you
know his big skid loader on it and tears
it up you know ruts it up and all kinds
of stuff by not you know by going too
fast or you know turning too quickly
which you know it takes me 15 minutes to
go over there and smooth it back out
it's not a huge deal but it's it's
it it's just the premise of it I don't
go over to their house and run up their
yard right so what you just gave me is
also
um
I hesitate too but I call that a
character issue
I I had somebody come and absolutely
trashed my yard recently a vendor came
and just rotted it up and they wrote me
a check for it
because they were taking care of they
were taking care of their business it
tells me if he's gonna come put huge
divots and not realize that he's just
completely rutted up your field or right
up your driveway and he's not doesn't
say hey man I'm gonna take care of that
I'm gonna come get it fixed up that's a
character issue right that's a sit down
and say hey man you came over and
trashed this it or really made this
difficult this that was hard that was
hard for us I don't have time to come
back and fix this stuff up I'm really
grateful for your help but all
ultimately here's the deal you're trying
to piecemeal this what about this what
about this what about this and in your
head
how in the world can you go bush hog
down five foot trees that's insane
I'll tell you it's just a city guy I
mean it sounds insane but I I can see
myself doing that just trying to be
really helpful so it's really helpful
for a guy like me who loves to help who
loves being outside to have some clarity
over what's right and what's not
that's number one being super clear the
second thing is being direct choosing
guilt over resentment I want to be the
person who does this so would you please
stop mowing my yard at all please don't
do any bush hogging on the yard please
don't be on the on the driveway that we
just had redone I'm working here's my
picture here's what I'm trying to do
here
and he might get his feelings hurt he
might feel guilty but if you feel
comfortable saying hey this happened and
this happened and this happened here's
what I want to do I just want to stop
all the work on the place and I want me
and fiance to work on it and it might
also be really important for her since
you're not even married yet
um for her to sit down with her dad
and say Hey Dad we want to do this thing
together just us two just grind it out
ourselves
um which we need you to stop doing work
on the place and we want to own what
happens from here if you want to have a
contest see who's who's acreage acreage
looks nicer cool we can do that but
um otherwise I'm telling you it might
not be bleeding over now but you're
gonna start getting frustrated with your
wife because it's her dad and you're
gonna start getting frustrated with
yourself because because the clarity or
this that choose guilt over resentment
every single time and dude none of this
is easy don't you hear me say this is
easy at all I got a great father-in-law
love talking to him he's a great guy
just at my house
this would be a hard I'm just imagining
this would be a hard conversation for me
to have with him anybody trying to help
but I still have to have the
conversation still have to still have to
make it happen